die haushaltswoche im bundestag in
wenigen augenblicken spricht der
wirtschaftsminister robert habeck die
einzelnen ministerien äußern sich in
dieser woche zu ihren ausgaben und heute
ist das wirtschaftsministerium dran wir
sehen hier schon die live bilder aus dem
bundestag und bei uns im studio ist
bildpolitik chef jan schäfer schönen
guten morgen ja humor du bist heute
deutschlands schnellste meinung machen
sorgt also ordner ist also ein was der
bundeswirtschaftsminister gleich zu
erzählen hat ja es wird eine spannende
rede oder anders gesagt eine mit
spannung erwartete rede robert habeck
steht unter druck wie nie zuvor in
seiner politischen karriere er ist ja
ungefähr seit 20 jahren politisch aktiv
war unter anderem umweltminister in
schleswig holstein war grünen-chef und
jetzt ist der bundeswirtschaftsminister
seit einem guten dreivierteljahr und
erlebt das erste mal eigentlich wirklich
wirklich massiven widerstand das hat man
ihm gestern auch angesehen gestern auf
der regierungsbank also den großen
schlagabtausch gab zwischen olaf scholz
den bundeskanzler und dem cdu csu
fraktionschef friedrich merz und heute
nun ist robert habeck selbst dran ich
würde sagen er wird das sehr versuchen
sehr routiniert runter zu spielen aber
möglicherweise gibt es massive
zwischenrufe auch und das macht die
ganze debatte natürlich gleich besonders
spannend ist er überfordert kann er das
seiner meinung nach noch
robert habeck hat mit viel persönlichem
einsatz versucht er diese krise an der
er mit sicherheit nicht selbst schuld
ist persönlich selbst schuld ist zu
meistern aber wir sehen dass robert
habeck in dem am wasser hat wirklich
überfordert ist deutschland regt sich
auf ist sauer und der grund dafür ist
natürlich robert habeck der
wirtschaftsminister sein merkwürdiger
auftritt im fernsehen bei maischberger
deutschland hat angst in diesen tagen
verständlicherweise vor weiter
steigenden preisen vor einer pleitewelle
ja und der wirtschaftsminister er
stammelt und kann sich nicht richtig
äußern seiner meinung nach könnten
firmen zwar aufhören zu produzieren
würden deshalb aber nicht insolvent
seien ja und genau das treibt viele
bäcker jetzt auf die barrikaden
ich bin 48 jahre alt selbstständig wir
haben zehn angestellte in unserer
kleinen bäckerei ich fordere sie auf
treten sie zurück was sie hier verzapfen
in deutschland ist der größte mist den
nachkriegszeit erlebt hat sie haben doch
wirklich mit dem füllen geduscht oder
sich mit einem hammer gekämpft bitte tun
sie deutschland eingefallen treten sie
zurück nehmen sie die frau bot kreis mit
und den scholz die mit dem gratis
obendrauf er wird sich sowieso nicht
mehr daran erinnern dass sie mitgenommen
haben aber tun sie unserem land
eingefallen und gehen sie einfach danke
harte worte von diesen becker was oder
wie der wirtschaftsminister das gemeint
haben kann das wird erst jetzt ein
bisschen klarer weil offenbar sollen
jetzt in der energiekrise betroffene
unternehmen mehr unterstützt werden es
gibt die gefahr von betriebsaufgaben und
der müssen wir begegnen deshalb werden
wir die hilfsprogramme erweitern sagte
der vizekanzler zwar gebe es einen
schutzschirm unter denen auch kleine und
mittlere unternehmen schlüpfen könnten
sagt der grünen politiker aber es ist
klar für den herbst und winter müssen
wir den schutzschirm größer aufspannen
man arbeite mit hochdruck damit firmen
zielgenauer und wirksam unterstützt
werden könnten so habe ich zum
redaktions netzwerk deutschland
[Musik]